israel obtuvo una prórroga al limitar
los viajes a los países afectados por o
micro en el mes pasado pero como dijo
naftalí bennett esta se está acabando
con la aparición de decenas de casos
confirmados y sospechosos de la variante
alemán con el tiempo que compramos está
agotando omicron ya está en el país
desde la que knesset a los jardines de
infancia y se está extendiendo
rápidamente no podremos parar esta ola
pero ustedes pueden protegerse dentro de
esta ola de heads bajo pala
israel cerró en gran medida sus
fronteras tras la aparición de omicron
no se permite la entrada de extranjeros
y todos israelíes que llegan del
exterior deben pasar la cuarentena el
gobierno espera que esto evite la
necesidad de confinar pero es devastador
para el sector turístico que tuvo que
volver a parar tras reabrir brevemente a
principios de noviembre
una segunda navidad después de los
tiempos de coronavirus esperábamos que
estas navidades volviéramos al ver
turistas aquí en israel desgraciadamente
y como saben todavía los turistas no
pueden venir a israel de visita los
israelíes ya tienen prohibido ir a
varios países europeos como reino unido
países bajos y desde el domingo francia
el primer ministro también recomendó a
los israelíes que trabajen desde casa
cuando sea posible e instó a los padres
a vacunar a sus hijos
[Música]